eh bien nous allons passer à la deuxième
épreuve qui va nous conduire à
saint-amand là encore nous avons utilisé
le nom d'une émission que nous
empruntons à ne pas me pierre sabbagh
avis aux amateurs avoue léon zitrone
match je crois que le micro marche
maintenant merci je vous allez voir un
match où il s'agira d' après un jeu
renouvelé et du temps où nous étions
jeunes
il s'agira de faire poser à l'adversaire
le bras sur la table voulais vous
montrer la prise messieurs s'il vous
plaît vous ne commencez pas encore je ne
vous ai pas présenté voilà vous devez
vous voulez vous s'il vous plaît
monsieur vous laisser battre là pour ce
coup ci ça ne compte pas pour que les
téléspectateurs puissent voir voilà
et lorsque son poignard a touché la
table ou l'autre le match sera
considérée comme terminée le point
accordé
vous êtes de saint-amand monsieur viser
les cinq hameaux comment vous
appelez-vous gens m'a sauvé votre
profession mineurs votre poids 72 kg à
tournus bien ça fait soixante douze
ennemis le pantalon vous monsieur
vedette de dates vous appelez la pique
la pique votre profession mais aussi
envers les 220 et votre poids un peu
plus un kilo bravo monsieur
messieurs vous êtes prêts vous êtes
prêts non non non ne commencerais pas
monsieur je vous en prie je vous avez
raison de vouloir gagner pour
saint-amand
mais laissez moi vous donner le départ
on peut tjrs allez messieurs alors vous
commencerez à mon top le pain ne tirais
soyez gentil monsieur messieurs
messieurs mesdames messieurs mesdames et
messieurs les téléspectateurs soyez
gentils nous avons un peu de désordre
ici
mesdames et messieurs de la foule de
saint-amand je vous demande s'il vous
plaît d'avoir la grande gentillesse de
ne pas crier de manière qu'au moins ces
messieurs puisse l'entendre leur donner
le top de départ n'est pas facile je
vous remercie à la main alors voulez
vous monsieur poser votre coude et vous
le vôtre à voulez vous vous posez mais
non monsieur on ne joue pas encore alors
posée
vous apparaissez simple répétition
après-midi veut qu il allait battre aux
longs cheveux bal qu'on paye bras alors
messieurs si samba pas fait obligés
d'annuler l'épreuve voulais vous poser
le coude
je la voulais vous poser le coude alors
qu'est ce qui vous manque et notre table
messieurs si vous ne vous êtes pas guy
lux ces messieurs ont des difficultés
pour poser le coude
ils ont eux mêmes choisi la table je
vous propose d'annuler le jeu m
mathieu va écouter
je vous en prie le jeu alors messieurs
nous allons partir comme cela
messieurs nous sommes sur l'antenne pour
l'amour du ciel
voulez vous écoutez je vais essayer les
merlus messieurs voilà vous y êtes là
comme ça ça ben oui léon zitrone vie je
vous ai qui vient il sera dit que c'est
au jury le pari de décider car nous on
ne peut pas changer la morphologie de
deux individus
il semble qu'il y en a qui est un bras
assez long l'autre à brax plus court
c'est tout au moins ce que les images
m'ont laissé penser depuis quelques
secondes vous n'arriverez jamais à
raccourcir le bras de l'un ou allonger
le bras de l'autre en l'occurrence étant
donné l'évidente mauvaise volonté des
deux compétiteurs enfin je n'interviens
pas je crois que c'est au jury de paris
de décider si le bras le plus court doit
se mettre à la hauteur du bras le plus
long et cela simplement par l'adjonction
peut-être d'un simple petit livre sous
le bras
je vais demander au jury de paris de
bien vouloir dire sinon dans le chaos
n'irai pas de décision à prendre à qui
le jury dans le coin eh bien mon cher
guy je crois que c'est la fête des mères
ce soir région a décidé cela eh bien
messieurs est ce que vous avez bien
entendu la question car nous on vous
entend très bien alors c'est épatant
vous avez entendu qu'est ce que vous en
pensez ce que quelqu'un parmi vous a
déjà une opinion là dessus je le pense
en ce qui me concerne
je pense quant à moi sur les deux
antagonistes devront poser leurs coudes
sur la table est au top se prendre la
main
je dois quand je dois dire d'ailleurs
très rapidement que nous avons
suffisamment attaqué guy lux pour la
difficulté ou disons quelque partialité
dans laquelle se trouvait mais je dois
reconnaître honnêtement qu'il n'est pas
toujours facile de déterminer la trace
et de l'accueil
mais c'est dans cette émission est
passionnant vous êtes de cet avis
messieurs oui je pense pour ma part que
si l'on mettait quelque chose pour caler
le droit du monde
mais quelle sur le bras le cultive
ensuite je pense que si ça paraît
d'après une compensation toute façon
pour aimer alors il y aurait des
difficultés à zurich
quant à lille où la table où nous et il
faut bien qu'ils aient une compensation
pour celui qui a droit une vanne en sera
de sa poche la blu ray genou droit et se
prendre la main au top de départ
alors guy lux avez-vous bien entendu
cette suggestion bien je dois dire
qu'ici c'est l'hilarité générale à dax
malgré le poids perdu tout le monde est
très gai tout le monde est très confiant
je n'ai pas tellement bien entendu je
m'excuse des mythes et léon zitrone
n'est pas très bien entendu mais je
pense que la décision vous avez prise
est la bonne voulez vous la transmettre
à léon zitrone et si possible qu'on en
termine avec cette deuxième épreuve
malgré toute originalité qu'elle peut
revêtir bon cher y trône voilà ce que
propose le jury des maires de paris vous
m'entendez bien lever le bras si vous
m'entendez
épatant et bien le jury des mers propose
que ces deux messieurs mettent leurs
coudes sur la table à une certaine
distance l'un de l'autre sans se toucher
la main est au top les deux mains iront
s'empoigner si j'ose dire le coût de
touche toujours la fin mai que le couche
le coude touche toujours la table ne
défend difficile plus exclue messieurs
vous êtes d'accord avec un deal jury de
paris
le jury de paris vient de dire je vous
demande pardon la sonorisation des fans
le jury de paris vient de niche que vous
posez vos coudes comme ils sont je vous
dis trois deux un cop et vous prenez
vous prenez la main et vous souhaitons
la main ouverte la main ouais voilà ça
va comme ça les coupes touchant toujours
la table messieurs la marche
alors messieurs vous êtes prêts trois
deux un top c'était bon départ
le point à dax mais déterminé le point à
dax le joueur de saint-amand s'est
enlevée